c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir ces nouvelles manifestations
au soudan est juste deux jours après la
démission du premier ministre des
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées dans la capitale soudanaise
et sa banlieue pour protester contre le
pouvoir militaire des manifestations
réprimées par les forces de sécurité
une centaine de partis politiques se
mobilisent en guinée il lance une
plateforme d'opposition pour veiller au
maintien de la démocratie réunis autour
de l'opposant cellou dalein diallo ils
craignent que la junte au pouvoir ne
s'installe dans la durée nous serons à
conakry dans ce journal et à la fin de
cette édition va aiguiser votre appétit
nous irons à la découverte d'une
gastronomie d'afro fusion c'est un
concept inventé par un chef congolais né
à brazzaville il s'est inspiré de la
cuisine des grands mères pour concocter
ses propres plans
les forces de sécurité soudanaises n'ont
pas hésité à faire usage de gaz
lacrymogènes pour disperser les
manifestations à khartoum et dans sa
banlieue des dizaines de milliers de
personnes s'étaient rassemblées pour
dire non une nouvelle fois au pouvoir
militaire deux jours après la démission
du premier ministre abdallah en doc
khartoum de nouveau noyée sous les gaz
lacrymogènes les forces de sécurité
soudanaises tir pour disperser les
manifestants qui scandent des slogans
contre l'armée le pouvoir militaire qui
a mené un coup d'état et a fait vaciller
une transition vers un régime civil
cette manifestation intervient deux
jours après la démission d'abdallah and
docks le premier ministre civil
soudanais qui lors de sa nomination en
2019 incarner l'espoir
la limitation de amdocs n'affectera pas
l'opinion du peuple parce qu'elle est
construite sur le mensonge le 25 octobre
dernier abdallah amdocs est évincé et
placé en résidence surveillée
rétabli dans ses fonctions un mois plus
tard dans un nouveau conseil souverain
purger de ses ministres civils les plus
actifs est toujours dirigé par les
militaires il perd la confiance de la
rue
bien que sa démission soit arrivé
tardivement nous en avions besoin ils
n'étaient pas censés travailler main
dans la main avec les putschistes
sa démission pourrait ouvrir la porte à
de nombreux problèmes au soudan nous
pourrions perdre des martyrs et l'armée
pourrait étendre son pouvoir
sa démission ne fait que précipiter le
soudan dans une nouvelle période
d'incertitude
en deux mois la répression des
manifestations a fait au moins 57
victimes et des centaines de blessés la
rue doit désormais faire face au seul
maître à bord dans le pays le puissant
général al bouraq
la mise en place en guinée d'une
plateforme politique une centaine de
partis sont à l'origine de cette
initiative ça s'appelle collectif des
partis politiques
il s'agit d'un front entre la junte
militaire soupçonné de vouloir se
maintenir au pouvoir la nouvelle
coalition été lancée ce mardi au siège
de l'opposant cellou dalein diallo les
explications de notre correspondant à
conakry mali diakité à travers cette
plateforme ces leaders politiques en
faire des propositions concrètes au
conseil national de rassemblement et de
développement pour la réussite de la
transition un espace à des changements
que les différents partis politiques du
pays afin de parler d'une seule voix à
la gente militaire sur des questions
liées à la transition depuis le coup
d'état du 5 septembre dernier la junte
au pouvoir n'a en gros engagé aux
comptes dialogue avec les partis
politiques et une situation que déplore
ces leaders écoutez nous avons mis en
place un comité de coordination qui sera
composée de 14 personnes qui vont
réfléchir et travailler pour définir la
position de ce collectif par rapport à
la constitution par rapport au code
électoral par rapport à l'organe de
gestion des élections mais également par
rapport au chronogramme et à la durée de
la transition nous sommes dans la
transition et nous souhaitons
chacun à ce qui nous concerne d'avoir
une transition réussie et les questions
qui se posent des questions éminemment
politique et je pense que la classe
politique a son mot à dire sur les
questions politiques qui se posent en
guinée la guinée reste au jeu suspendu
des instances de cedeao l'organisation
sous régionale qui exigent des élections
dont les prochains mois a déjà infligé
des sanctions individuelles aux membres
de la junte militaire au pouvoir
l'incendié qui a ravagé le parlement sud
africain était maîtrisé ce mardi un
suspect arrêté dimanche dans son
enceinte a été brièvement présenté
devant la justice l'homme de 49 ans a
été présenté devant le tribunal
correctionnel qui a renvoyé l'audience
au 11 janvier le suspect restera en
prison en attendant
le gouvernement tunisien finalement
dévoiler la raison de l'emprisonnement
d'un ancien ministre de la justice ne
dîne thierry est suspecté de terrorisme
membre du parti islamiste ennahda il
avait pourtant joué un rôle majeur dans
l'accession au pouvoir de l'actuel
président kaïs aides mais ce dernier
étant entre-temps entrer en conflit avec
le parti à relire
nourredinne bhiri
vice-président des narda arrêté vendredi
en tunisie a porté plainte contre le
président kaïs sayed et le ministre de
l'intérieur pour qui un happy c'est ce
qu'a rapporté la défense de l'ancien
ministre de la justice en réponse le
ministre de l'intérieur tunisien assure
que cette arrestation n'est pas
politique et en révèle finalement le
motif
il existe des soupçons graves de
terrorisme dans le dossier
des marées il fallait que je sois à la
hauteur de leur responsabilité pour
sauvegarder la sécurité de la tunisie
l'ex-ministre préoccupe d'abord par son
état de santé son parti l'a annoncé en
grève de la faim nourdine bhiri
refuserait aussi tout médicament alors
même qu'il est atteint de plusieurs
maladies ce lundi la famille biri
décrivait cette arrestation comme anti
dumping politique
ce n'est pas une résidence sous
surveillance c'est un lieu secret il
existe donc des lieux où les personnes
qui ne la pression garder on pensait
qu'après la réponse fin de 2011 n'aurait
rien de tout ça mais selon une
délégation de l'un stance de prévention
de la torture et du haut commissariat de
l'onu aux droits de l'homme nourdine
bhiri est hospitalisé depuis dimanche
sous surveillance rapprochée en
cardiologie à bizerte dans le nord de la
tunisie
est justement des voix critiques se font
de plus en plus entendre en tunisie il
ne s'agit pas que de dénoncer les
arrestations d'opposants à c'est le mode
de gouvernance du président kaïs aide
qui est visé il gouverne par décret
après avoir prolongé plusieurs fois le
régime d'exception reportage de lilia
blaise et de gamme dit lily
dans ce local appartenant au parti de
l'ex président moncef marzouki critique
de kay sayed ces figures politiques
opposés au président sont en grève de la
faim depuis plus de dix jours certains
ne travaillent plus après le gel du
parlement comme cette députée du parti
ennahda elle dort avec les autres
grévistes sur place 1 dingreville voilà
la chambre dorment les femmes on a tout
installer ici pour avoir tout ce qu'il
faut à proximité nous présente même
s'ils ne sont qu'une poignée de
personnes ils réclament un retour à
l'état de droit menacée selon pour doter
les enfants vivent dans un vide
constitutionnel et juridique
nous demandons le retour à une forme de
légitimité démocratique et ensuite nous
pourrons entamer un vrai dialogue et aux
noces gitanes
actuellement le climat politique en
tunisie et tendu les conditions
d'arrestation du vice-président du parti
islamiste ennahda nourdine péri ainsi
que d'un ancien cadre sécuritaire
soupçonné dans une affaire de terrorisme
ce vendredi inquiète les défenseurs des
droits humains des annotations était
musclé et il n'y a pas eu d'information
pas là pour l'analyse honda les stations
et ans s'inquiète pour le deuxième
détenu mais se fait label d
nous n'avons aucune nouvelle par rapport
à la situation des juristes déplore le
flou juridique qui favorise ces abus
dont 20 pays sous régime d'exception est
sous état d'urgence on ne sait pas
quelle est la base juridique de tout ce
qui se passe maintenant ce n'est pas la
constitution même le décret de soixante
dix huit sur la base duquel il ya eu des
arrestations dernièrement et des
assignations à résidence et c'est même
le président de la république de son
propre aveu a reconnu son
inconstitutionnalité
donc on continue à appliquer des textes
liberticides
malgré ces voix critiques le président
reste populaire dans les sondages une
consultation nationale va être lancée en
ligne le 15 janvier pour questionner les
tunisiens sur des réformes
constitutionnelles et législatives
plus que cinq jours avant le coup
d'envoi du premier match de la coupe
d'afrique des nations au cameroun une
compétition très attendu même si
certains craignent que la fête ne soit
gâchée en raison de la menace
séparatiste et djihadistes dans le pays
jules bois tout
ali mais au cameroun c'est déjà la fête
pour la mascotte de la compétition
pourtant la région méridionale qui doit
accueillir plusieurs rencontres de la
coupe d'afrique des nations est en proie
depuis quatre ans à des affrontements
violents des groupes armés tentent par
la force de former un état séparatiste
dans cette partie anglophone du pays des
violences qui ont fait près de 3500
morts et plus de 700 mille déplacés mois
est fier mais lilibet diniz and is d'ad
dim sum phenomenon
bombe last
boy a dit
à frohmuhl
certains indépendantistes ont d'ores et
déjà promis de perturber la compétition
autre inquiétude les attaques jihadistes
même si leur intensité a baissé ces
derniers temps le groupe boko haram et
son rival de l'état islamique en afrique
de l'ouest restent présents malgré la
menace les autorités se veulent
rassurantes
comme le chante
commission
la compétition dont le report a un temps
été étudiés se tiendra aussi dans un
contexte sanitaire tendues avec la
déferlante du variant omicron dans le
monde mais pour les locaux elle est
synonyme d'espoir après des mois
difficiles
[Musique]
face à la menace les organisateurs ont
annoncé des mesures sanitaires renforcés
pour éviter tout foyer d'épidémie dans
les stades ou parmi les équipes
et avant de se quitter je vais vous
emmener à la découverte d'un chef
congolais qui s'inspire de la cuisine
des grands mères de tout le continent et
qui crée sa propre gastronomie ses
propres plyce il appelle sa part dont la
france fusion lui s'appelle dieu veille
malonga et il est installé au rwanda
scheer les sites vous en dit plus
le mot laboratoire n'éveille pas souvent
l'appétit le labo restaurant de dieu
veille malonga est une exception à la
règle ce chef né au congo a étudié la
cuisine en allemagne et en france
perfectionnant son savoir faire dans des
restaurants prestigieux son talent il
l'a ramené en afrique où il crée de la
cuisine un frau fusion walk like on
l'appelle à profusion on peut avoir des
épices du nigeria ça peut être du poivre
noir du nigeria vous pouvez avoir de la
banane plantain d'ici au rwanda je peux
avoir de la viande du bruni
tous ces ingrédients viennent de
différents pays et nous créons une
recette à partir de ces éléments que
nous avons
le chef explorateurs à déguster des
plats traditionnels dans 38 pays
africains ramenant des secrets et les
meilleures épices pour créer son propre
menu revisité
quand j'obtiens une vieille recette je
la porte dans mon laboratoire c'est
comme ça que nous appelons le restaurant
et nous essayons avec mon chef de lui
apporter une touche moderne la plupart
du temps je m'inspire de cette recette
de grand mère pour créer quelque chose
de nouveau est censé union le but n'est
pas juste de créer de la bonne cuisine
dieu veille malonga et d'autres chefs
ont créé un réseau de 4000 chef
travaillant déjà sur les plus grands
rendez vous internationaux pour amener
l'afrique au sommet de la gastronomie
mondiale
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut
[Musique]
mais tu es fou rythmes de l'afrique
la coupe d'afrique des nations du 9
janvier au 6 février sur france 24
portugaise pendant des siècles avant de
devenir indienne goa est devenu dans les
années 60 le rendez-vous des hippies
c'est nous qui avons créé la musique
l'art le mouvement écologique et tout ça
une nouvelle forme de résistance
politique une nouvelle forme de
conscience
mais la terre promise a vite été envahie
par le tourisme de masse que reste-t-il
de cet héritage culturel cosmopolite
billet retour revient à goa sur france
24 et france 24 points comme